- [Voiceover] In the figure above,
triangle ABC is isosceles.
So that's triangle A, B, C,
so that big triangle, that's isosceles,
which means two of its
sides are congruent,
have the same length.
That is, side AB, they explain it here,
side AB, so side AB here,
is equal in length to side BC.
So these two sides are equal in length,
so we could say that side
is equal to that side,
actually I wanna be careful just because
that looks like I'm
saying it from that point
to that point, but those two blue sides
are gonna be equal in length.
Triangle DEF.
D, E, F
overlaps with triangle ABC,
you know we see that,
they kinda formed this,
this star of David, or kinda this skewed
star of David.
What is the value of angle p here?
Alright.
Let's work through this.
So ABC is an isosceles triangle,
and I'm gonna draw it separately here,
so ABC is an isosceles triangle.
This is an isosceles triangle,
and an isosceles triangle, if these two,
if these two sides are congruent,
then these base angles
are going to be congruent.
And they already tell us
that this angle up here,
they already tell us that this
angle up here is 100 degrees,
and we know that all the interior angles
of a triangle add up to 180 degrees,
so if we call this x degrees
and this is x degrees,
then we see that x plus x plus 100,
plus 100 is going to
need to be equal to 180,
or we can get that 2x,
2x and then if we subtract
100 from both sides,
is equal to 80, or that
x is equal to 40 degrees.
So just that like we're
able to figure out that
both of these, both of
these, are going to be
equal to 40 degrees, and
that came straight out
of the fact that ABC is
an isosceles triangle,
these two base angles are
going to be congruent.
So this is 40 degrees
and this is 40 degrees.
Now let's go to this little
small triangle right over here,
this little small
triangle right over here.
Once again, we know
that the interior angles
of a triangle add up to 180 degrees.
So if this right over
here, actually this angle
right over here is going
to be the same as p
because it's vertical, it's
a vertical angle with p,
so this is going to be p degrees as well,
and now we see p plus 40,
p plus 40 plus 60
plus 60 is going to add up to 180 degrees.
That's the interior angles
of this little small
triangle right over here.
Or we could write p plus
if we add the 40 and the 60,
you get 100.
p plus 100 is equal to 180.
If we subtract 100 from both sides,
we get p is equal to 80 degrees.
So what is the value of p?
Or I guess this is p degrees.
So the value of p is,
the value of p is 80.